Alright, now we are doing the images for the website.
So we talked a little bit about images in our previous module.
We have said that the best practice is to ask your client for pictures.
If you do not have pictures from your clients, I am going to show you how to get some free
images.
My favorite one is actually Adobe stock images.
You are more than welcome if you know none of your clients are going to give you images
and you need to buy some.
It is definitely worth to get a subscription there.
If you only need a couple, I would do the free trial.
The free trial usually up to this day, it includes 10 images.
Because we need 25 images, you do need to create 3 accounts just to get those 25 images.
It can be time consuming to use the free trial.
That is why this is up to you if you want to pay for them or not.
But there is a free trial option, especially for the first site.
I already went ahead and made an account.
Right here, if you are making the free 10 photos account, I am only going to show you.
Keep in mind that you need 25 pictures, but we are only doing the header one and we will
do 4 more pictures underneath just to show you what the rest is going to look like.
Right here, it will tell you how many assets, so how many pictures you have left to use.
Right here, again, when we are looking for pictures, you want to make sure that you are
looking, especially when you are getting stock photos, that they look not stocky.
You want them to look like you are a local company, you actually took those photos.
Make sure you are familiar with what the area looks like.
Obviously, we are located in St. George, so it is very similar to Arizona.
But I am still going to look at what homes and residential properties look in Queen Creek,
Arizona, which is the area that we are focusing on for our website.
I want to make sure that the images that I am putting on the website look like they are local.
So make sure you are going on Zello or anything like that to look at houses or whatever niche
you are going into.
So, let's start with something more broad.
Concrete driveway.
And keep in mind, you can use any other, you don't have to use Adobe Stock.
If you just go into Google and type free stock images, you will get Shutterstock, which has
some good ones, you will get iStock, Pexels, Unsplash, anything really.
So go ahead and use whatever you want as long as you follow those guidelines that we have
said before.
So, let's see.
The header picture is usually the hardest one because the header picture, you really
need to pick one that is looking good because it is going right here.
So, let's see.
This could be in Arizona.
Ok, let's go ahead and download this.
So, just click on license right here.
Ok, it's going to download it right here.
And if you really like the photo up here, it's actually going to give you some other
ones that are similar.
This could be in Arizona too.
It's not a great driveway, but it may work.
Ok, I think this one is pretty, could be, this looks pretty general.
We have three.
I don't know if I like any of those to be my header photo, so I would like my header
photo.
And your header photo could even be a picture of Queen Creek, like a city or a neighborhood.
Let's see, maybe if we type Queen Creek, Arizona.
Let's see if they have any good ones.
Alright.
Ok, maybe Arizona.
Get creative with how you're searching.
Like for example, if you're going into, I don't know, Alabama and you know that in your
city that you're going after, there's a lot of brick homes, you can actually just search
brick home.
If you know the exact type of house that you're looking for, you can just type that.
This actually looks perfect.
I'm pretty sure there's a stamped concrete.
So, that would actually work.
Let's see, this one would be a good one.
Ok, we already have four.
I think that's stamped concrete.
Um.
But because I'm not sure, just do a quick stamped concrete driveway.
This is when you want to be careful.
Make sure that what you're putting up is exactly what you're looking for.
Ok, yeah, I think that's stamped concrete.
Ok, this would be a really good header photo.
Ok, let's download and we should have all the images that we need.
Ok, let's go back to our website.
There's the header photo right here.
Now we need to optimize the images.
So we need to make them SEO friendly because even images are important when it comes to
ranking, when it comes to optimizing your website to be Google friendly.
So one thing that we want to do is when it comes to optimization of your images, there's
two very important things.
One is resizing the images.
The other one is renaming the images.
See how right now they're called Adobe stock?
Well, nobody that is Googling for your website will see that that photo is called Adobe stock.
Google will and they don't usually like that.
So they want to know exactly what that photo is instead of being an Adobe photo.
And so we're going to rename them.
Now let's, we resize every picture except for the header one.
Usually the header one we don't need to resize because the header picture needs to be at
least 1200 pixels to even look not blurry.
So let's Google a free image resizer.
And again, there are so many options out there.
Just pick one that works for you.
I've used this one before.
A simple image resizer.
So select image.
Download.
Okay.
Let's resize this one.
Usually I want to do it by dimension.
And I would keep them under a thousand pixels.
But usually I like it to do between like 300 and 400.
Let's see, 450.
Okay, that looks silly.
So maybe let's try the percentage because this is not a square picture.
It's hard to make it look natural.
So maybe let's do 30% smaller.
Oops.
We need to select it again.
This one right here.
Okay.
Okay, but we don't really know how many pixels that is.
So let's try different free image resizer.
Okay, let's try this one.
Drop it there.
This should work better because he tells you exactly this is way too much.
So let's make it.
Okay.
And he already tells you this is perfect because you want to keep it max 400
and he already automatically picks a hyphen.
That won't make it look funky.
Let's download the image.
Perfect.
Now I like to open the image immediately.
Now let's go ahead and change the name.
So click here.
And the name of the image really just can be a keyword.
So have your keyword list on hand, whatever you're doing on page SEO
because you're really going to use the keyword list.
because you're really going to use it.
And it's really easy when you have an image pulled up
because all you need to do is look at what the image is and describe it.
So this is a concrete driveway and that is going to be the name of the image.
You can even put the location that you're trying to target.
So Queen Creek.
And I'm going to save this on my desktop.
You can say whatever you want.
Just make sure you know what it is when you need to add it to your website.
Perfect.
Now let's go back
to our images.
Let's do the next one.
OK, 400.
OK, I'm going to name this.
Because the driveway does not look like it's concrete,
but the sidewalk does.
So I'm going to name this concrete sidewalk.
Perfect.
Let's do
let's do another one.
I should do this one.
OK, this could be the concrete walkway.
It looks like it's stamped concrete.
We can even put the cord of concrete.
Image.
Rename it and do not use the same names or the same images.
Always be creative and use a different name for each image.
So, um, the cord of
concrete.
OK, let's do the next one.
Concrete.
Perfect.
And
so far we have three.
OK, we need another small image,
which I believe is this one.
And then we're going to work with our header photo.
Oops.
OK, right here.
OK, let's see.
OK, this one.
And let's do the same thing.
So for 100,
you can even do 300 if you want to be extra safe.
The reason why we make them smaller
is because
if you have very large images, they look very nice,
but the website takes a longer time to load.
And these people are calling themselves
a contractor.
They want things done.
So if if you
I mean, think about the times that you have searched something
on the Internet and the website was really, really slow to load.
You have probably clicked out of it and clicked a different one.
So that's the reason why we want to optimize things
to make the website load fast.
OK, and we can actually name this stamp to concrete.
So let's download
so let's download
rename
stamped concrete.
Make sure you're spelling everything correctly
and don't leave spacers, by the way, when you're renaming.
So how I have a space right here, that won't be good.
So have everything put together.
OK, and now, lastly, we're going to worry about our header photo.
So let's click out of here, select image.
Make sure it's this one.
Awesome.
So it's four point three.
It's a little big.
So I would probably do two thousand.
That should be better.
You can also crop it, but you can do that in Weebly as well.
So let's try it.
If it doesn't work exactly how we want it,
we can always go back here and edit it.
And how I like to name the header photo is usually the company's name,
not the client name, but our company that we have created with this website.
So in my case, that would be Queen Creek Concrete.
OK, I'm going to save this on my desktop where I have all my other ones.
OK, now back to Weebly.
So we have optimized images.
We have resized, renamed.
OK, let's go back to Weebly.
Right here, let's do the header first.
See how that looks.
So you're going to click on replace header layout.
Oops, just kidding.
You're going to click on edit background.
Click out of color, click on image and replace.
OK, upload image, upload a photo from your computer.
OK, right here is our header image.
Let's click on open.
OK, that looks good.
So you can actually, if you hold on to the mouse, you can actually move this around.
I know the house is really nice, but you also want to make sure that people can see the driveway.
So let's keep it that.
Click save usually gets a little bigger.
Perfect.
So you can, if you click here, this little dot, you can make it larger.
OK, that should work.
I think there's a space here.
There's not.
OK, let's go ahead and add our phone number here.
What we like to do, if you have a very colorful image, sometimes it's hard to read.
So we like to do something.
Whatever we have done right here with the color block, we put in the header.
So go ahead and add that up here and let's drag the title in here and the phone number.
OK, let's actually add the company's phone number.
So go ahead and copy that.
Either go on call real, make sure that everything is very detail oriented.
So make sure the phone number double, triple check that it's the exact one that you want
it to be.
Make sure that it's linked to a click to call to the same phone number so people can actually
click and call.
Let's make this smaller.
A little bigger.
All right.
We don't need the color block to be that big.
And Weebly doesn't allow you to make things skinnier.
So a trick to doing by doing that is to put a spacer outside the color block and see how
now you can make it more skinny to fit in there.
So put it outside of the color block and you can actually fix it to fit in there.
And then we can make the color block less of a block by clicking on it under background
transparency.
You can make this less so you can actually still see through the picture behind it.
But it's you can see the letters more and you can make the color block like you can
round the corners.
This is up to you.
I like to round them a little bit so it's not so harsh, but you can do whatever you
want.
And then I usually like to put a divider in between so I have a nice line.
OK, let's make see what this looks like on the mobile.
OK, I don't love I usually like everything to be in a line.
So just switch things up.
If you see this, just go into the theme, change the fonts to make something that looks
better and more aligned.
OK, and now you can also I'm pretty sure if we put a spacer above, it should screen.
No, that won't work that way.
So let's get rid of that.
OK, let's see.
Let's make this a different color.
OK, that looks better.
And then let's change this to be.
OK, let's change the and now that we know what the header looks like, it's easier to
make a form for it.
So we can even do you can round the corners of the form as well.
OK.
Let's do let's just see what a yellow would look like.
Don't really like that yellow.
So let's grab.
Maybe we just need to do a gray.
OK, now that it's really hard to see the font.
This is a little annoying.
Whenever you're going with a dark color in the form, you just have to click on theme,
click on fonts and then paragraph text.
You're going to have to make that white and then it's going to be invisible here.
So you have to manually make that black.
But that's OK.
I don't love.
That.
Don't love you, neither of them.
OK, we want to make this white.
You can actually see it.
You probably want to make this yellow.
Like the phone number.
And obviously, this is not I mean, there's no rule in this.
It's whatever you think looks decent.
I would probably go with it.
There.
You can also make the form like a little smaller.
I feel like that looks better.
OK, now let's highlight every piece of content.
Make sure and this is can be annoying.
But it's important that you are paying attention to the font.
You can also make the font smaller.
I feel like that looks better.
OK, now let's highlight every piece of content.
Make sure and this is can be annoying.
But it's important that you are paying attention to.
This is already black.
OK, so the rest of the content is good to go.
Now, let's add the corner image right here.
So just click on here.
Upload a photo from your computer and.
Let's do this one.
I don't know if you remember when we were putting this into the desktop
into the mobile phone.
Look, this content would actually be disappearing.
So well, when you add an image, as I said, in the module in the second
module, this comes back.
So OK, go back to desktop and you're going to do the same down here
with the other three images that we downloaded.
So one.
Two.
Three.
All right, make sure the pictures are looking good.
One thing that I like to do, and this is totally up to you, just giving
you ideas where the pictures are.
You can put it like a dark gray.
You can match the same dark gray as the quote form.
And then one last thing you need to do to optimize your images
to be SEO friendly is click on the image right here.
Go all the way to advanced and make sure you have an alt text.
An alt text is pretty much another description of what the image is.
So I'm pretty sure if you are.
Like have some kind of disability and you can't see the image,
there is a way that you can see the description of the image.
And that's what the alt text is also used for is for people to identify
whatever is on the image.
So just be descriptive about it.
For example, this could be stamped.
Concrete for house.
Walkway.
And you're going to do this for these three images
and all the other images as well.
And then make sure you're always publishing after you're done.
And that's all you have to do.
So do that for all 25 images and you're good to go.